mr. Warner can you tell us what happened
to that gem million dollar and mostly
excuse me these norsu morning could you
tell us where we come in 10 million
dollars in your comment use your
comments your comments mr. Warren away I
meant no comments do i do I want to do
let's go men why would you explain to
people who are going on yeah every not
coming that's good me handle me what mr.
I'm talking to lament give while on the
water but why will you tell them to pi
wonder women when you tell the loans
apart about this avalon children can you
stop loving me washed up when your
country on being made up i would you
like aahh officer are you gonna stop
this man assaulting me no unless you use
a beautiful man i'm talking what are you
against mr. against mr. bladder mr.
Warner as a parliamentarian do you think
it's right for your associates are
assaulting me mr. 10 of you you move
move excuse me right what gives you the
right to assaulting still wanna why
won't you talk to us you've got nothing
to hide so why won't you talk to us